800 fans I'm Liana Galera coming to you
live because each is at comic-con right
now with the life of Taylor and Bob
Marley from the hundred hi guys it's
always a pleasure welcoming you into the
suite thank you so much for taking the
time but I've got to talk to you about
something mmm it was a it was a lovely
June afternoon and I was sitting on
Twitter and all of the sudden the
internet exploded because you guys
shared the delightful news that you got
married congratulations
first of all House newlywed life going
for the two of you this came as such a
sweet surprise to all the hundred fans
out there because not only did they not
know that you were dating but they have
no idea that you guys were even engaged
or getting married can you talk to us a
little bit about your decision to kind
of keep this close to your hearts well
yeah but you guys have been sharing
scenes together for the past six years
I'm curious to know Bob when did you
know that Eliza was the one
well what I do want to do right now is
do a little celebratory toast for you
guys because we're so excited to hear
the news so we went ahead and pop some
champagne for you and so what cheers
congratulations
Richard Hartman joining us right now
Richard how are you doing right now
Murphy is going through such an amazing
journey in season so I'm certainly doing
better than Murphy is I can say that
much well Murphy ever find happiness I
feel like I've been waiting for him to
actually find that elated moment yeah
like it's never gonna settle down farm
somewhere and you just kind of relax I
don't know if that's what's in store for
his life but I'm not fast in store for
anyone
this new planet comes with a lot of new
challenges
Eliza it's been so amazing to see you
play this dichotomy of Clark and
Josephine when you found out that you
were going to be playing two people in
one mind what was your initial reaction
oh my god
am I gonna be able to do this yeah it
was scary you know I know Clark back to
front that playing a completely
different character in the same body it
just it seemed just really out there but
I think it worked out yeah yeah it's
really fun well let's talk about episode
ten it was an extremely emotional
episode I especially want to talk about
the CPR scene what was it like for the
two of you guys to play it and Eliza are
you doing okay because Bob those were
really intense
CPR yeah luckily we had like a pretend
me yeah it was it was a really emotional
scene I think Bob did all the heavy
lifting though I had my eyes closed oh
thank you I was in the middle of
prepping for my episode so I didn't I
was on location and like scout location
and then came in and did that and then
had to go back to amazing service it was
pretty quick and yeah I mean a man it
was great the director yeah it was such
an insane
yeah it was a it came off on screen as
such an emotionally charged moment I
almost felt like a real turning point
for Bellamy and Clark's friendship what
can we expect from them moving forward
this season well you know I mean okay
you had mentioned though that episode 11
is the episode that you directed so
congratulations New Year's again - that
was very exciting yeah that's a proper
cheers was the biggest challenge for you
stepping in front of the camera while
also being
the camera I think you know the scenes
that I was in that's pretty hot I think
yeah
he's gonna step up and do it and yeah
over before I thought about it and then
I was in the editing room I think yeah
yeah I was gonna say it Richard now put
him on blast how was he as a director he
was terrific
he finally say that I am in the episode
and I mean I was I think I've never been
more nervous to work with the director
of my life than it was for have one of
these before
yeah so my best friends just wanted to
be really good and I mean he let's just
work and kind of play this is just a
pleasure really yeah you did a job and
it was clear how much you loved it yeah
Eliza you were just saying that you were
wanting to give a good performance for
him what was it like seeing him step
into this new chapter of his career I
was amazing
and he took to it and he plans to direct
any more episodes or any other projects
yeah I mean we actually wrote something
when I was in Australia and now a little
brother congratulations
before we can talk about season seven
we're still we've got to get through
season six
we've already had such a crazy time on
this new world you guys have more time
jumps than any other show on TV 125
years into the future what are you most
excited for fans to still see the rest
of season six bridles chaos yeah I mean
we've been counting going this way the
entire season and setting it up and kind
of getting to know this planet and this
civilization that's been running for a
couple
years already yeah yeah so I think it's
all been kind of coming to this climax
and I'm kind of I'm Lucia definitely
we've already seen your characters go
through so much over the past six years
as we go into season seven what is still
on your hundred bucket list what would
you like to see we'll start off with
would you like to see from Murphy seven
I'd like to see him finally make up his
mind about what he deems his morality is
like that's what I've loved kind of
playing that compass but eventually he's
gonna have to decide and make a choice
I'm kind of what side he's on but that's
the great thing about the show there's
so many it's it's a real great for
everyone and what you're kind of able to
do and have to do to survive it's not
always morally okay so I'd like to see
him maybe fall on one side of the line
but I don't know I'm just I'm just
excited to see what they have in store
from if he makes it that far fingers
crossed I mean you made it six years
what about for Bellamy I think we know
us to bury the hatchet with Octavia and
kind of finally move on to some sort of
different storyline hopefully you know
once again what happens yeah and what
about for Clarke I just love to see I
kick back on a bait she's gonna tan you
know that's it really that sounds
amazing yeah if we could find a beach
that'd be great she's like so much what
maybe they all should just go and search
for another planet that's a little bit
more relaxing one thing I do know is how
much I adore you guys thank you so much
for sitting down I really appreciate it
thank you for choosing the bus and thank
you for all the fans keep it locked to
eat eat live because we're gonna be
coming to you live from comic-con and
we're gonna get these superstars over
into our photo booth and you can check
out all the photos on social media bye
guys
you